Hampton sides author of ghost soldiers
why do you think this book went right to
the top of the bestseller list I think
it's a story that is largely forgotten
and it's a story that when you find out
about it this is the way I felt about it
when I first learned about this you
can't believe that you weren't taught
this in in school with with you know
like this rescue that took place which
was one of the largest rescues in
American history when you firt when I
first heard about it I couldn't believe
that this wasn't part of like the
shorthand of American intrepid acts like
this Rough Riders in at San Juan or or
the Alamo it's just one of those stories
within the larger story of the Pacific
that I just felt I just couldn't believe
wasn't better known and I think that
explains part of it I think another part
of the reason it's done so well is that
this is a gigantic group of people I
mean 20,000 Americans between Bataan and
Corregidor surrendered every one of
those men had family members and so many
of these stories were never told because
they returned to America after the war
didn't want to tell these dark stories
the sort of dark chapter of an otherwise
successful or good war and as only as
they've come to the end of their lives
they felt increasingly comfortable about
telling these stories and getting into
it deeper when did you first know you
had a hit you remember well this we were
able to get an excerpt first serial in
Esquire magazine and the magazine was
very very interested in when it when the
when that happened we knew there was
something else going on here besides
just a military history book and the
letters that we got from from that
excerpt were also very very interesting
and I think very telling that we had
tapped a nerve of some sort here that
was much bigger than I mean there's tons
of war books published every year and
many of them are marketed expressly for
just a military the military buffs and
this one was was clearly striking a
nerve with the general public as well as
family members of Bataan where is this
the title from ghost soldiers ghost
soldiers really is a resonant phrase
that refers to within the camp itself
cabana tawan which this was the largest
powa and
American history ever established on
foreign soil these guys referred to
themselves as ghosts all the time the
ghosts of Bataan they would call
themselves because not only do they look
like ghosts from having lived for three
years in squalor in starvation in these
camps but they felt like they had been
forgotten by by the land of the living
and by by their own country so you see
it in the poems and songs the camp
literature the ghosts of Bataan I just
thought it was an interesting kind of
phrase resonant phrase and played off of
that help me on the pronunciation we've
had people here to call up a tan and
you're calling at the time I've heard it
both the actual way the Filipinos say it
is but two on with a little bit of a gap
there but uh you know I generally use
the pronunciations that the Americans
used because primarily I'm following the
American version of the story what I
call it Bataan what is it
but tun is a peninsula that juts out
into Manila Bay and it's full of
volcanoes and jungles and was a perfect
place the American High Command realized
to fight a protracted defensive war when
the Japanese invaded very quickly
General MacArthur realized that they
were not going to be able to defend
Manila so they pulled back into this
peninsula of land and held out as long
as they could the the original war plan
which was known as war plan Orange was
to hold out just long enough for the the
resupply of ammunition and food and and
medicines from the Navy from from Pearl
Harbor but of course there was no Navy
anymore because primarily the the Navy
was destroyed with the attack at Pearl
Harbor and suddenly these men on Bataan
were caught without prospects for
resupply on this peninsula they held out
as long as they could 3-4 months and
then on April 9th
finally starved and suffering from
malaria and dysentery and every other
country one disease uh this is in forty
to forty jape April 9th 1942 they
finally pulled up the white flag and and
and surrendered to the Japanese the
unthinkable thing had happened the
Americans had had lost the battle and of
course they'd never talked about
surrender
they didn't know they didn't really have
any plan or protocol for how you go
about giving up your arms to to the
enemy so thus began one of the darkest
chapters of the war the which came to be
known as the Bataan Death March page 10
of your book let me just read a little
bit you say a navy single man named Cece
Smith refused to go into his pit
suddenly the Buzzard set upon him he
raised his saber high so that it gleamed
in the midday Sun and with all his
strength he brought it in it blade side
down Smith's head was cleaved into the
sword finally stopping Midway down the
neck where's that from where'd you get
that I opened the book with an incident
that happened at a different prison camp
altogether called Porter princesa in on
the island of Palawan also in the
Philippines and the reason I open the
book with this account is that it it was
the example of what the Americans were
worried what was going to happen
at this other camp my camp cabana and
tawan in this incident that I'm
describing there that you just read the
Japanese saw that the Americans were
returning and decided to take their 151
POWs that were under their command and
they lit them on fire they poured
gasoline on them and lit them on fire
they it was a part of the Japanese
policy to not let anyone be turned back
over to the Americans for fear that
maybe they become fighting soldiers
again one day or live on to tell about
the war crimes that they had witnessed
so the American command returning to the
Philippines and this is skipping ahead a
little bit to 1945 when they found out
about the existence of this other larger
camp cabana 2-1 they were worried that a
massacre much like this was going to
happen and so they realized they had to
do something sends the men behind enemy
lines
ahead of the lines and try to extricate
these guys before another Massacre like
this would occur how many people how
many Americans died in this incident in
that instance well 151 were involved 140
died the rest survived either
for a short while or there was actually
seven or maybe I think it's ten who
actually survived uh made it home and
told their story to the world and yet
it's an incident that is extremely
obscure obscure the massacre at palawan
is not very well known today even among
the Bataan and Corregidor guys anybody
that was there alive today there as I as
I know of there's only two and I spoke
with one eugene nielsen who's a mormon
gentleman lives in the mountains in utah
and it's just extraordinary tale of
survival that he was able to escape this
massacre he basically jumped over a
barbed wire fence down onto a beach and
hid and various cave like folds in the
coral reef
ventually he jumped into the bay and
started swimming he was shot three times
somehow swam for nine hours with bullet
wounds made it across the the bay
dragged himself across a mangrove swamp
and eventually hooked up with Filipino
guerrillas in order to tell his story to
the army intelligence people so all of
this figured in ultimately to the army
intelligence as they decided what to do
with this other camp Cabana to one
palawan happened what year Palawan this
massacre happened in December of 44 so
basically one month before the Americans
were returning to Luzon so it was a
cautionary tale basically and he found
Eugen Nielsen and the mountains of Utah
yep he's still alive
tough tough guy early 80s I believe and
and he is just extraordinary what he
what he had to go through just to
survive to tell the storage of the world
and where did you find him I mean I'd
you find by phone or just him in person
I uh yeah I think I just used the phone
or you know phone directory I knew his
name I knew he lived in Utah and I just
there was a couple of Nielsen's and
eventually located him he was reluctant
to talk to me at first why uh well I
think anyone who experiences a truck an
atrocity like this it's just very very
difficult for them to talk about it and
who the heck am I you know he didn't
know who I was whether I was trustworthy
he's little hard of hearing you know I
think was just a little difficult for
him to get going on it
also I found though that this this
particular incident that we're talking
about was the subject of a war crimes
trial and here in what in the Washington
area at the National Archives in College
Park Maryland I was able to find
hundreds of pages of documents of
testimony from people like Nielson and a
couple of the other survivors so I was
able to piece it together with
excruciating detail I mean it you know
everything that happened at palawan was
fairly well documented by these ten or
so survivors this whole thing I'm going
to read it again this is a Japanese
soldier raised his saber high so that it
gleamed in the midday Sun and with all
his strength he brought it blade side
down Smith's head was cleaved into the
sword finally stopping midway down the
neck how do you know that's true and if
it is does it say anything in particular
about the Japanese three or four
different people mentioned this this
particular incident this was a guy who
was refusing to go into the trenches the
Japanese had made the Americans willing
earlier for their own safety to dig
arraigned eight air raid trenches so
that when American planes which had
begun bombing palawan months earlier
when these bombs would drop the
Americans would go into these trenches
and hopefully not be bombed by their own
by their own fellow Americans the the in
this incident the Japanese acted as
though there was another air raid that
was imminent and they said getting your
air trenches get in your trenches and
this one guy this gentleman here refused
to get in his trench he didn't
understand he didn't hear American
planes coming he didn't know why he
needed to get in the trench and that's
when they set upon him with a sword the
fate of the other Americans was they as
soon as they got in the trenches the
Japanese came with aviation fuel and
sloshed it into the trenches with
buckets and then lit the trenches on
fire with with bamboo torches but there
were a number of witnesses to this
particular incident so and I feel very
very confident that the details are
accurate but the second part of question
does it say anything about the Japanese
and you find more of this kind of
activity well you know the book is full
of there
vivid accounts of Japanese atrocities
and they viewed prisoners of war very
differently they had ideas from their
culture borrowed from the days of the
Bushido code of samurai days that the
ultimate shame was to fall prisoner to
surrender to the enemy was beneath
contempt
and you were supposed to save the last
round of ammunition for yourself so I
think this influenced the way they
treated the American POWs they were you
know they didn't feel a necessity to
treat the Americans with any delicacy
and they didn't and of course this
happened repeatedly through throughout
the book there are the examples of this
sort of brutality I went to Japan for
three months to study this whole
question of the prisoner prisoner hood
status but where did this idea come from
you know and and how at what lengths
would they go to visit these sorts of
cruelties on prisoners uh
you know it wasn't in generally with
their treatment of the POWs it it wasn't
a like a Nazi policy of extermination or
anything like that it was what I call
malign neglect basically letting them
wither on the vine not feeding them not
letting basic medicines come into the
camp by and large these deaths of the
American prisoners weren't the result of
this sort of cruelty that we were just
now discussing but just basic diseases
like dysentery and malaria that were
flourishing in the camp because the
Japanese command would not permit basic
medicines like quinine to get into the
camp and you know they just didn't feel
it was necessary they didn't really
understand why a prisoner of war should
be treated with any delicacy they didn't
they didn't really get the whole Geneva
Convention idea what year did you start
working on this
I started this about three years ago I
live in New Mexico and I had come out to
New Mexico and kept seeing the word
baton baton Memorial Drive Memorial
Library on April 9th there's a Bataan
Memorial Day where they raise a white
flag over the State Capitol in Santa Fe
and I didn't know what baton was frankly
I you know I was I think I've since
become appalled the
level of my own ignorance because this
was the largest surrender in American
history and the largest and I think most
heinous captivity experience in American
War history and I knew very very little
about it it was only the vaguest
reference for me the reason there's all
this Bataan Memorial stuff out in New
Mexico is that more people from New
Mexico than from any other state were
caught in the Bataan Death March and
half the guys that went over there
didn't come back they took an entire the
entire National Guard of New Mexico
turned them into an artillery unit and
sent them to to the Philippines just
before the war so consequently you know
you had this tiny state in terms of
population just devastated by this event
so I got more and more curious that way
I started meeting these veterans and
then I well I was also at that at this
point I was an editor at outside
magazine outside magazine writes about
you know adventure sports and the
outdoors and all sorts of extreme and
situations that people put them in put
themselves into you know expeditions of
one sort or another we published Jon
Krakauer who you know in thin air and
Sebastian Junger a story that later
became the perfect storm and when I came
across this story of Bataan it felt like
familiar ground it felt like an outside
magazine story
you know except set in the 1940s and you
know far-flung jungles and men having to
really endure the endure hardships that
were that made him you know made the
outside magazine stories seem kind of
tame so it felt familiar to me what year
were you born I was born in 1962 where
Memphis Tennessee and how long did you
live there I'm up until college you know
18 years or did you go to college I went
to Yale studied what I studied not much
of anything I studied history but I
mostly worked on campus newspapers and
magazines and and I guess my big mentor
in college was John Hersey the writer
who whose very first book as a matter of
fact was about Bataan it was called men
on Bataan he was a correspondent with
time life and was over there
interviewing soldiers just before the
surrender and I was very much
by his book hiroshima in which he
instead of telling the overview story of
the bombing he decided to tell it from
the point of view of five or I think
it's six characters that's sort of what
I did in this book is instead of telling
the the big macro story and what was
happening in Washington and what was
happening in Tokyo I was more interested
in what was happening on the ground with
five or six main characters and you
can't you know come to care about these
guys where were they from was their life
like before the war so that when these
atrocities begin to happen to them you
care about their fate and hopefully if
it works that that's the theory anyway
for with this kind of narrative and
Hirsi was was a real big practitioner of
this kind of journalism where you you
know you get really personal and you
tell it tell history through the eyes of
individuals where did you meet him at
Yale he was a teacher at Yale taught a
nonfiction writing course that was I
think you know very influential on my on
my career what year did you graduate
1984 and then what did you do uh well
I'm INF in Washington working for
various newspapers and magazines I
freelanced for places like the
Washington Post and The New Republic and
tried to figure out what kind of
journalism I was interested in I became
apparent to me after a few years in
Washington that I didn't really want to
cover politics and I didn't want to do
sort of source journalism or public
policy journalism it just wasn't my
strength but I didn't know what I really
know what I was after I came to realize
that I wanted to do narrative very much
like John Hersey had done in his in his
career so I wanted to I eventually left
Washington in search of bigger stories
um I wrote a book called stomping
grounds which was about American
subcultures classic American groups that
have annual epic reunions that that
almost like going to Mecca groups like
Tupperware sales ladies people who are
Lee David sand motorcycles Airstream
travel trailer owners you know the
silver bubbles and group called the
rainbow people which are hippies that
meet every year in a different national
forest and it was my first book it was
just it was a ball to do I traveled
around 38 states and told these tales
about American subcultures and why we
seem to be drawn to these
eternity zuv intensely like-minded but
but somewhat esoteric pursuits where's
the name Hampton sides come from how'd
you get Oh it's a is this one of
southern you know last name first names
I'm from Memphis and I'm ultimately
named after general Wade Hampton who was
a famous general during the Civil War
although I'm not related to him it's
just some kind of family name that
somewhere along the line I think I'm the
third so it's it's been in the family
for a while what's the origin of the
name sides sides is actually a German
name it was sites and uh I guess maybe
at Ellis Island or somewhere they
changed it to or anglicized it a little
bit turn it into sides and why Santa Fe
and why did you move there when I moved
out in Santa Fe out to Santa Fe about
seven years ago I took a job at outside
magazine which was then in Chicago but
was planning a big move out to Santa Fe
outside has always been oriented towards
the Rocky Mountains and towards uh you
know mountain climbing and kayaking and
doing all kinds of stuff like that
and so it made sense that the magazine
would move to a town in the Rockies and
I I knew they were going to move and I
wanted to raise my family out there and
it was just what the doctor ordered get
out of Washington DC and do something
very different how BIG's your family I
got three I got three little boys oh
four six and eight and my wife and I
raising them out there and in the wilds
of New Mexico
they're pretty feral at this point
pretty crazy it's never dull around our
house now go back to the batana
is it a memorial or a museum in Santa Fe
both there is it the only museum
dedicated to Bataan is right there in
Santa Fe they also have a thing every
April called the Bataan Memorial Death
March it held on the White Sands Missile
Range
thank God they don't actually recreate
the conditions of the of the original
Death March it's really just a it's a
military marathon where they invite all
the survivors back to to greet the
runners and then the runners take off
into the desert and run 26 miles well
the year that I got interested in this
book I found out that there was a guy
from the original baton who wanted to
walk the route of this memorial death
march
in honor of his comrades and his name is
Winston Shillito he's still alive he was
in phenomenal condition anyone at that
age I think at that point he was 77 or
78 anyone of that age who's able to walk
26 miles and add altitude like that it's
got to be in pretty pretty good shape
and I did a story for Sports Illustrated
about about this this man in this event
and this whole whole idea of synthetic
suffering that I was kind of playing
with this idea that you know there
there's real authentic suffering and
then there's this sort of tendency we
have increasingly to seek out these
incredible hardships and you know that
are optional you know like now I think
I'll go climb a certain mountain without
oxygen or a paddle across the ocean in a
bathtub or in a run 26 miles in the
desert so it was it was a strange event
to see this man this man this man
walking this route thinking about the
ordeal that he had suffered fifty some
odd years before and yet being in the
company of all these ultra marathoners
and their bright clothes and all their
regalia you know running this event and
kind of comparing these two events is it
safe to assume that this book would not
have been written without the baton
museum and the death march reenactment I
mean is that I think it's true that you
know in the early stages I was I was
casting him out for a book I knew that I
wanted to get out of editing because by
that point I had been editing it outside
for a while and wanted to do something
drastically different and it's true when
you start when you embark on a project
the first few experiences that you have
are I think extremely influential and
pivotal and this story really did like
so many stories it began locally and it
began just by looking around in my
hometown in my home state and asking
some real basic questions you know what
what what was baton exactly I've heard
the phrase Bataan Death March but if I'm
this ignorant about this then I'm
banking the banking on the fact that
probably a lot of other people
especially people of my generation are
similarly ignorant and and you know one
one
thought led to another led to another
and so you know I think all great
stories uh start local Ian's in some way
how many printings have there been for
the book I know there they were in the
fourth printing last week so and we've
got time between now and the time of
errors books are in the market uh I was
told a half-million so I don't I don't
know you know how many exactly I've been
sold versus how many are in route to to
various publisher to various bookstores
but the book is selling extremely well
better than we could ever imagined and
you know this book was never intended
for just a simply a military history
buff readership but by this by the same
token you know a lot there's a lot of
war books out there and you know that we
had no particular reason to think this
one was going to be any different but it
the very first week it was out it was
number seven on the bestseller list and
it was at two for a while and it's been
two or three or or there abouts ever
since so it's been very gratifying to
see this level of interest you say the
Bataan Death March was twenty six days
well it lasted different lengths of time
for different people did it depends on
when you started and which which guard
you had and for all the dates that it
started on April 9th 1942 and lasted for
a couple weeks
from what point they left most of them
from the tip of baton place called
marvelous and went north village by
village as fast as they could go but of
course that was the problem by that
point they were so sick and so did
pleaded and so racked with diseases that
they couldn't move like how many there
were anywhere from eight to ten thousand
Americans who surrendered it's hard to
know the exact number because many of
them swam across the shore of the Manila
Bay to Corregidor the little island and
or some just disappeared into the jungle
hoping to hook up with other Americans
and develop a guerrilla force but
approximately will say 8,000 Americans
went on this death march and
approximately a thousand died enroute so
Cabana two on which this is all about is
located where it's on the island of
zhan about 60 miles north of Manila it
was the largest American prison of war
camp ever established on foreign soil it
was it has it had as many as 9,000
people there at one time and it was a
little tropical enclave of America there
you know they tried to establish some
semblance of an American town there the
thoroughfares were named you know there
was like a 5th Avenue and Broadway and
and Main Street they called one of this
one of the thoroughfares the place where
they had the camp meetings was known as
Times Square you know they had a
baseball diamond they had a camp library
and a university they called it a
university where the better educated
officers taught classes in a strong
astronomy and French to the enlisted men
they tried as best they could to carry
on and have some some semblance of order
and and American society there to the
extent that the Japanese would allow
them how many Americans were inside the
camp the number fluctuated wildly
because the the Japanese were
continually moving them on details for
one one work detail after another they
worked on roads and bridges and
shipyards but through much of this
period of 42 43 44 the number was
somewhere around 5,000 and then as the
Americans started winning the war and
the tide was turning against the
Japanese they decided to start shipping
the able-bodied American POWs North to
Japan to work in the coal mines of Japan
and and so the numbers began to dwindle
down to finally to 500 people the last
500 who were left in the camp when the
Americans returned how many people died
inside they camp about three thousand in
mass graves all those people were
disinterred at the end of the war and
reburied in a military cemetery near
Manila well in Manila that I went to
during the research of this book more
people died there than any other camp in
in American history outside of the Civil
War itself
what did they die of they died of
dysentery malaria
berry-berry all sorts of insidious
combinations of those three those were
the big ones they died of all kinds of
nutritional deficiencies a lot of
esoteric ailments that cropped up when
people were starved
not just for weeks or months but years
you know of basic medicines I mean they
were they they were primarily eating
rice month after month after month and
they didn't have for example vitamin B
because they didn't have vitamin B they
were developing berry berry which is a
hideous disease it causes the
extremities to swell up and eventually
you basically drown in your own your own
pus essentially it's a hideous way to go
and that's what happened to so many of
these men
and lots of even more esoteric diseases
cropped up these guys became night blind
or lost their vision altogether some of
them lost their voices some of these men
grew breasts essentially their breasts
swelled up and became tender and there
was a strange disease called limber neck
where they couldn't hold their head up
their neck became like rubber and like
literally hundreds of men would walk
around the camp with her what you know
holding their head holding their neck up
with their hands so all these kinds of
strange things were developing because
you know they didn't know it wasn't
starvation in the sense that I mean they
were getting a little bit to eat every
day but they weren't getting basic
vitamins and minerals over a prolonged
period of time and that wreak havoc on
their constitutions and the Japanese had
what control over the Philippines during
this time period well they weren't they
were you know they were running the show
from Manila they wanted to use Manila
Bay because it was you know one of the
best harbors in Asia and the the
Commandant of the camp there were
actually a number of different comma
downs over the years but they would come
up come up from Manila and each
Commandant would have his own rules and
regulations they they ruled with an iron
fist they went into this conflict
thinking that the Filipinos would would
accept their rule because they were
Asian and Filipinos were Asian and
you know the slogan was Asia for the
Asiatics and they felt that they would
freeze felt that the Filipinos would
forget American rule and and and turned
their allegiance to a new power but that
didn't exactly happen the Filipinos were
were still very loyal to the Americans
and although there were plenty of
collaborators by and large they didn't
cooperate with the Japanese and you know
there was an underground there were
guerrilla organizations they made life
quite difficult for the Japanese
occupation
how many Japanese were on guard there at
the prison most the time usually around
100 guards and these guys were I mean
you know this wasn't the cream of the
Imperial Army most of these guys were
either extremely young green kids fresh
from Japan or older older folks alte
pastures people who are sort of brought
in after their military career was
really over a lot of them were brought
in from Korea and Taiwan which were run
you know basically ruled by Japan and
stuck out there in the Philippines a
thankless post so naturally they were a
little bitter and sulking and didn't
want to be where they were and I think
this influenced the way they treated the
American POWs the actual time that your
book focuses on well there's two basic
timelines there's one timeline is three
years and that's the story of the men of
Bataan their surrender their captivity
experience leading up all the way to the
day they're liberated the other timeline
is three days and that's it took three
days when the Rangers got this mission
to go in and liberate these men to to to
the point where they got them back
safely to American lines and one of
those three days three days were January
28th 29th and 30th of 1945 and you know
at a certain point in the book these two
timelines finally intersect and and you
know the tension is broken when the
gunfire starts at the camp
what would you say overall has been your
most important source
well privately these men themselves I
mean and primarily that I mean the POWs
the Rangers were very helpful to me the
Rangers were very modest
they their memories were not
particularly complicated they went in
and did their job they had an
extraordinarily successful mission and
you know there they had no problems
talking to me but the POWs the these men
that that are pictured in my book are
you know this is primarily their story I
talked to them for hours and sometimes
days I went to their houses met their
wives and families and stayed with them
as long as possible it became apparent
to me that the way to tell this book
going back to her see in Hiroshima was
to really tell it through the eyes of
just a handful of characters keep coming
back to him you see it through their
eyes and you know picking a
cross-section of men who represent a
fair diversity within the army of that
time men from different towns in
different different places who's just
fellow right here this guy is the guy
who who led the mission to cabaña to one
his name is Henry musi Colonel Henry
Meucci they called him little MacArthur
because he like the Supreme Commander
had a high appreciation of the theatrics
of warfare he smoked a pipe like
MacArthur he was a character loud very
charismatic he Allah musi mutants not
alive he died a couple years ago
unfortunately I was talk to him no I was
not able to talk to him he he died just
before just before I embarked on this
project resist all but this is the
number two the guy under musi who
actually went into the camp and devised
and planned and executed the the assault
on the camp name his name is Robert
Prince great name for a rescuer captain
Prince amazing guy he lives in Seattle
Washington
he's a hale and hearty and tough as
nails very modest like so many of these
Rangers he he doesn't really understand
he doesn't think this was extraordinary
what he did this is what he looks like
today this is what he looks like today
you did meet him I met him a number of
different times but this particular
photograph was taken at a very mu
moving reunion that was held at Fort
Benning Georgia to commemorate the raid
on command and tawan it was the only
time that all the surviving Rangers and
all the surviving POWs were brought
together in one place and they're in the
liberated got to got to embrace the the
liberators it was a really moving thing
and prints showed up and you know it was
terrific to see all these guys together
in one place and you were there I was
there and a number of other journalists
it was it was a reunion that was
completely paid for by one of the POWs
who just wanted to do something out of
it out of his heart to thank these guys
and there was no plaque or memorial of
any sort at the Ranger Hall of Fame
which is there in Fort Benning Georgia
and this guy I paid for the plaque and
the marble and everything and and
invited all these guys to fly in from
all over creation which they did gladly
and got to see all these guys together
in one place how many of them
asked us because I noticed it in the
back when you talk about where they are
today how many of them died in the
middle of rewriting this book a couple
of couple of the main characters died
while I was researching and even while I
was just beginning to think about who
might be the main characters of this
book to a three of them died and I ended
up you know speaking to their spouses
namely I wasn't guy named sam gray show
out in spokane washington who who passed
away in the early stages of my research
the one of the main characters of the
book is a guy named dr. ralph Hibbs an
army doctor who was just a there's a
picture of him in near the beginning of
the very first block photos of my book
doctor Hibbs was it died just a few
months ago just before the book came out
I spoke to his his wife and he had just
passed away I was real interested in dr.
Hibbs because to a large extent this
story is a medical story you know
Japanese cruelty certainly accounted for
many deaths but ultimately this was a
medical story you know basic diseases
antique diseases diseases that we had a
handle on in civilized society
we're rearing their heads
for an encore performance in this camp
and you know without these basic
medicines you know is like going back to
medieval times and doctors having to
improvise fake their way through the
through operations without anesthesia
they call it they use what they call
vocal anesthetic which means the doctor
just says this is not going to hurt much
they use folk remedies of various sorts
and the dentist would make artificial
teeth from water buffalo teeth and you
know they had to improvise in all kinds
of ways which which I think you know
these these the the measures they had to
go to were heroic and the improv
improvising that they had to do was it
was was just extraordinarily creative
now you and your research had you found
another book like this anywhere there
are other books out there most of them
have been marketed explicitly for
military history audiences they're
pretty obscure many of them are
self-published books by people who
aren't writers but these were men who
were there and there are very important
documents I certainly relied on a number
of those books because you know they
were there and they told their story and
they finally got it down on paper some
of the men that became my main
characters had written their own books
and I was able to use their book as a
jumping off point for interviewing and
I'd say you know here on page 67 you say
this but what did you really mean by
that and can we get into that a little
more and it was a great sort of a
starting point for getting into these
interviews a little bit more intensely
as I was actually I listened to this on
on CD oh yeah while driving and as I was
listening to it and prepared to talk to
you about I kept thinking hah why would
an author want to tell us here today the
story of this book because the drama and
the story is what you're selling here
and if you had that problem as you go
about telling I mean there's some
there's some personal stories and I
haven't asked you about them yet but
does that hurt or help your sales you
mean the fact that these stories are
dramatic or women you could tell the
whole story here in an hour about this
book and oh I should really go by I see
we were saying yes well you know what
and in going
on the book tour we had to think a fair
amount about how much to give away you
know I mean I think it's apparent to
anyone who reads the jacket of the book
that we're talking about a fairly
successful fairly spectacular mission in
world war two and there was no way to
get it get away from that I think just
like John Krakauer with into thin air I
think when you read that book everyone
knows that there's going to be a
disaster on Mount Everest and and people
are going to die I think that's a given
the question is how you know given the
outcome that we all basically know how
do we get from A to B I think that's the
suspense and and there were casualties
there were things that went wrong there
were strokes of complete just good luck
and a couple of strokes of bad luck and
some Rangers died and there's an
incident involving friendly fire and and
so you know I think that we I don't want
to give away I don't mind giving away
the ultimate outcome it was successful
it's it's the question hi you know the
in between that's that's interesting and
that that I think the person who reads
the book will come to fresh story of dr.
Jimmy Fisher well now we're getting to
one of the stories I don't want to give
away too much but there was one of the
casualties was a doctor which sort of
seems appropriate in some way to this
story because the doctors were so much a
part of this story from the beginning
from from the days of Bataan and and now
with the rescue doctors figured into
this story so intimately this doctor dr.
Jimmy Fisher when I went along on the
raid he was the surgeon he was the
battalion surgeon of the sixth Ranger
Battalion and he wasn't supposed to be
at the raid itself he was supposed to be
in a nearby town getting the hospital
ready for the casualties that they all
expected were going to emerge from this
operation dr. Fisher ended up being the
cat the main casualty of this rate and
he was hit by mortar fire and was he
didn't die immediately but took about 24
hours he was was an amazing guy Harvard
educated guy who was it was very
important for him to be just just one of
the guys and
and to be right there with his man he
didn't have to be there he chose to be
there and at the point of greatest
danger and he paid the ultimate price
you say in your in your notes that
vivian hicks and his niece was a big
help to you on this how did she help you
well she had the all the family papers
what's interesting about dr. fisher is
that his mother was a famous writer of
the day and a famous editor who was part
of the book-of-the-month Club Dorothy
Canfield Fisher and she was very
studious about keeping all the letters
that she received after her son died
from all the Rangers from the doctors
who operated on him from the Filipino
guerrillas who were with him in his last
hours and there was photographs and yeah
you know letters from chrome you see
testimonials about his character and
what a wonderful man he was and all
those were assembled in one place and
she was just very kind and generous to -
let me take a look at all that stuff and
then ultimately all those papers went to
the University of Vermont Edmund Rose
what's that story oh well this is a this
is one you know whatever there's a
mission like this there's always some
some somebody who gets left behind
somebody who just is clueless to the
whole thing and Edwin Rose was was that
man in this case he was a stone-deaf
british civilian who somehow through
convoluted means it ended up in this
camp in the last few months of its
existence and when the raid commenced
and the gunfire started edwin rose was
he was sitting on the look on the
latrine he had dysentery and he was so
deaf that he didn't hear the gunfire and
the raid begins and ends all the
prisoners are removed and edwin rose
mrs. mrs. is at all and all the Japanese
were killed and all the Japanese were
either killed or wounded or retreated we
don't really know what happened to all
the Japanese because it was pitch black
but just recap you had a hundred to have
any soldiers there guarding 500
Americans right time of the attack right
you had about a hundred Japanese guards
and you had anywhere from 200 to 300
Japanese soldiers who were
bivouacking in the rear of the camp just
using the place to sleep and then there
was another thousand japanese soldiers
one mile away and another seven to eight
thousand four miles away in the in the
city of cabana tuan so the Japanese were
everywhere and in the midst of all this
edwin rose is sitting on the latrine
laboring mightily with his dysentery he
misses the whole raid he goes back to
his barrack and goes to sleep can't hear
can't hear and can't see very well
either and wakes up in the middle of the
night and realizes something's wrong he
smells smoke he wakes up
I guess it's right around dawn and the
realizes they're Japanese corpses
everywhere everything's different he
realized something big has happened but
he's still a little addled by by by the
whole experience and by you know his
nutritional deficiencies then he finally
it finally dawns on him that there's
been a rescue and he's been left behind
and he what he does maybe this is
typical British sense of pride and sense
of humor but he goes and puts on his
best suit there he had saved some some
clothing that you know he thought he
might need for for Liberation Day he got
dressed in his his suit he shaves
himself and tries to look you know sharp
goes out with his with his bag to the
front of the gate and just waits for
something to happen
and it could have been Japanese that
picked him up but in this case it was
some Japanese gorillas that intercepted
him and brought him to safety
made some Filipino girls uh Filipino
guerrillas who intercepted him and he
said I knew someone would come he was
very he was very optimistic that
something good was going to happen and
it did in his case he made it back to
England you do quote somebody saying
though I remember the exactly what
something like is elevated in right go
over the top floor right meaning did he
ate was he mentally deficient
he wasn't [ __ ] or anything like that
but he he was he was elderly and he had
I think the the cumulative effects of
the starvation had been harder on him
than on other people and you know he
couldn't see very well he couldn't hear
very well the you know cumulative effect
of all that made him a little slower
than most guys as I was listening to
your book by the way do you remember who
read it
James Naughton read it who's a Broadway
actors once on Tony Awards and has read
a lot of other books he's an old pro at
this reading books on tape why didn't
you do it oh I'm glad I wasn't asked to
do it it's it's a heck of a lot of work
and I've read things and done radio
interviews and radio stories for
National Public Radio it's a heck of a
lot of work to get it to get it right in
just a few takes I I think it would have
been really difficult for me to try to
do it's a slog through it
do you have any idea how the sales on
the audio part no I don't I don't I
gather it's doing reasonably well but
I'm you know it's amazing to me how much
they have to cut out of these books for
books on tape over 50% of the book is
gone and in my book you know isn't
terribly long book so you know I would
hope eventually there being an
unabridged version that would come out
the hotel tell the real story because so
many characters drop out so many of the
subplots are removed and you know it's
it's a shame to see some of that stuff
go 342 pages about $25 but no source
notes no footnotes do you make that
decision on purpose to do that yes you
know this is a narrative and this is
primarily journalism you know it's this
isn't history with a capital H where I
get deep into the you know what was
going on with McArthur or
what was happening in Tokyo or
Washington most of the guys if you were
to do an index example for example for
this book it would read it would it
would read almost ludicrously it would
read like you know captain prints page
43 blows his nose
page 57 develops foot blisters page 57
you know eats a raw egg you know it
would you know the this is a different
kind of story I mean it's a narrative
involving people most of whom are not
famous most of whose decisions were not
you know important in the larger scheme
of the strategy of the war this is an on
the grunt on the ground mission where I
was more focused on what their what were
their thinking what were they feeling
what what was the weather like what
one of the one of the roads look like
what are the rivers look like and to do
footnotes and and at you know interrupt
the flow of the narrative with numbers
and and get into all this and maybe
index all of this it just seemed like it
would be cumbersome and it would
interrupt the the momentum of the
narrative back we talked about when you
first knew that this might be a hit the
Esquire magazine article or excerpt from
this hmm
but back to the beginning of where did
you write it and how did you go about
that and how did you think that through
din order to get the narrative down so
that you thought people get brought into
this mm-hmm
well originally I was going to try to
write this book in strictly
chronological fashion just start with
men arriving in Manila war is imminent
they go to big they go to battle they
end up on Bataan they surrender they go
through the death march three years in a
prison camp finally on page 300 the
Americans return and there's talk of a
of a rescue but then I realized a couple
of things one is that you know to expect
readers to get through 300 pages of
dysentery and malaria and you know all
these exotic diseases and all the morale
you know just the demoralizing
circumstances that these guys were
suffering I realized was going to be it
was going to be tough reading and that
you needed something to ventilate that
long ordeal something to break it up
so I started thinking what would that be
maybe what was happening in Manila with
the underground maybe there could be an
escape attempt maybe I could go back to
some of the hometowns of these men and
figure out what their families were
we're doing during this ordeal or what
was happening in Washington it--you know
wracked my brain trying to figure out
something to break this long ordeal to
break it up with and then I but I
decided for reasons which I'm not even
still not sure why I did it this way I
decided to write the raid first kind of
write the end first and I started
writing what I thought was going to be
basically two chapters about the raid
the kind of the grand finale of the book
and two chapters became four became six
you know I started writing this
narrative and one of the amazing things
about narrative writing is that is you
start if you slow things down and you
and you and you start saying well okay
well what was he doing right there in
that moment what had they eaten lunch
yet
what was what time of day was this what
was the weather like there in this
village well what was the village like
and you know you start getting into all
the details and you realize that you've
you've consumed a lot of pages you know
like 50 or 60 pages for one of these
chapters that I thought was going to be
really short pretty soon I realized I
had perhaps 50% of the book was the
narrative of the raid and that that was
the way to break the whole thing up is
to kind of have these two timelines in
and have it syncopated in a way that you
know each each chapter you would go from
the prisoners to the to the raid itself
and back to the prisoners in the raid
itself each narrative kind of getting
closer and closer to a point where they
would ultimately intersect who are these
two men Adams and Abraham I don't know
who Adams is other than that that he's a
ranger on the right yeah the guy on the
left is a ranger
actually the guy on the right looks
looks like he's almost better fed
doesn't it his name is av Abraham he's a
Pio W is a tough-as-nails one of my main
characters a guy who was a Syrian
American from the steel country of
Pennsylvania I spent a lot of time with
a B at his house and heard his stories
just an amazing guy I'm what you know
really he was made of tough stuff I
think it was obvious from the beginning
when he was 16 years old this is a
picture of him when he when he was at
that reunion that we talked about
earlier but when he was 16 years old he
decided that he wanted to sit in a tree
for a long time he crawled up into a
tree and stayed put for four months and
won than the national tree sitting
record it sounds like a pretty dubious
pursuit I guess it is but he was
determined he was determined to to get
this thing and you know already
demonstrating I think his tenacity this
picture here is a
of him as a boxer when he went into the
army he became a very successful boxer
won tons of bouts down in Panama and
then in the Philippines was a coach of
the boxing team of the army so just
before the war I mean essentially that's
what he was he was it was a scrappy
tough boxing coach and I think survived
this ordeal just through sheer you know
just being tough as nails who's mr. or
in this case captain Burt bank
captain Burt bank he's he's from
Tuscaloosa Alabama he's the son of
Russian immigrants Russian Jews and he
is just a garrulous fun-loving
storyteller who got caught in this
conflict with the rest of these
characters and he's still alive today
came to the reunion good-looking man
he's what happened to him in this prison
prison experience is that he he went
totally blind he this is probably from
vitamin B or other vitamin deficiencies
but one day he was he was working out in
the out in the farm on this prison camp
and he was supposed to be pulling weeds
but he was pulling up the actual plants
the tomato plants and so forth and one
of the guards came up was going to give
him a clubbing and that something
happened I guess the guard realized that
they look on Burt banks face was pretty
vacant and he could it was clear that he
couldn't see what he was doing and from
that day on his eyesight got
progressively worse
and he was moved inside work work on
other details and he became totally
blind
he today he couldn't see his hand in
front of his face after he got back
after the war he he underwent a vitamin
regimen of some sort and was able to
restore about 50 percent of his eyesight
I when I went to Tuscaloosa he I rode in
a car with him he tried to drive from
from his office to his home and was one
of the scariest experiences I've ever
had I said I look I'll let me drive let
me drive this time and but but but still
I mean just a just an extraordinary guy
and somehow fakes is through situations
you said that you worked on this first
three years how much research and then
how much writing two years of research
and one year of writing and when if we'd
have followed you around for those two
years how many different places did you
go that would be hard to say I spent I
spent a month in the Philippines went
back there with a bunch of veterans from
World War two kind of saw it from there
from their perspective I went to Japan
for three months the rest of the time I
just spent tooling around America
looking for these guys well you know
once I found them and had conversations
with them on the telephone I would go to
their houses the first interview was in
Texas guy named Tommy Thomas I
interviewed down there in Texas and made
the mistake of renting a Japanese car it
was the only car they had it was a
Mitsubishi and yeah there's a picture of
him there his wife came out of the house
and looked at me and looked at the car
saw that it was a Japanese car and said
something like the nerve and ultimately
Tommy Thomas didn't he didn't care he
didn't he wasn't he didn't make a big
point about it you said that the
Japanese society underwrote your trip to
Japan the Japan Society it's a new
york-based group that tries to
facilitate cultural understanding
between Japan and the United States I
was surprised that they were you know
they knew all about the book and I was a
little surprised that they would be as
generous as that as they were but I made
it clear and I think I make it clear in
the book that I was trying to understand
their point of view try to understand
the cultural factors that influenced the
Bataan Death March and their views of
prisoner the prisoner would prisoner of
war status you know there were a lot of
kind guards there were a lot of
instances of individual kindness that
these prisoners I talked to remembered
and you know this is not a book for
someone who wants to someone who's a
japan basher is not going to get much
much satisfaction from this book so what
you learn though about writing a story
in your next book
well I definitely learned about re
learned all over again the power of
narrative I mean you know slow things
down talk about what's going on minute
by minute don't I think I'm much better
telling a story than I am at
analyzing a larger situation writing a
kind of an essay istic fashion I want to
do narrative in fact my next book is
going to be a novel a heavily researched
novel very much like this but it will be
fictions that have non fiction set in a
cave in deepest cave in the world down
in southern Mexico and some incidents
that happen down in this cave based on
some true events you've got a lot of
endorsements David Halverson Jon
Krakauer Erik Larsson iris Chang did you
have a first review that triggered
everybody else's interest mmm no not
exactly I mean Halberstam was the first
one that came in and that was that was
really really wonderful you know how
these blurbs work I mean you just send
these things out cold and you don't know
I've never met David Halberstam
I've read many of his books and was was
gratified to to say that he thought
highly of the book I think that that was
the first one and I guess that set the
tone for the for the other ones iris
Chang was was an important one to me she
had written a book about Nanking that
was you know highly thought of and and
very controversial and I did a lot I
think to acquaint Americans with the
Japanese Imperial Army of that day and
some of the some of the atrocities that
were perpetrated by the army where's
this picture on the cover from this
picture is a picture uh that was taken
by a Life magazine correspondent named
Carl Maiden's who did a great story just
after the raid took place this this
moment that he captured on film is the
very moment that they've crossed
officially over into American lines and
those are the Rangers they've got a big
grins on their faces because they've
just pulled off the spectacularly
successful raid they've been up for 72
hours and they've been popping
Benzedrine basically the US Army was was
handing out speed to the to the Rangers
so they could get through these long
missions and so the look on their face
is one part that they're wired on on em
fed amines and one part elation from
knowing that they've pulled this
spectacular raid off Hampton sides has
been our guest and we're out of time
unfortunately the name of this book is
ghost soldiers the Forgotten epic of
world war two is most dramatic mission
thank you very much thank you